hey what's up my name's Samuel Leeds and
in this video I'm going to giving my
predictions on the future of HMO
properties what's going to happen is the
future of house on multiple occupancies
good or is it bad is this supply and
demand what's going to happen is it
going to dry up are they going to become
saturated or HMO is going to become a
thing of the past my opinion is no I
think the HMO future is extremely bright
and as someone that invests in HMOs
myself in fact I bought my first
paycheck 11 years ago and I've been
training people in HMOs for the last
four or five years so let me explain
what I think and you can watch this
video back in 2025 and tell me that I
was right of course it's my opinion I
might be wrong I don't have a crystal
ball but I'm gonna explain why I think
the HMOs are gonna get more and more
popular and more and more lucrative and
I'll give you my thoughts on reasoning
behind that but first if you were a
subscriber of my channel thank you so
much please do smash the like button
also drop a comment and let me know any
thoughts if you're not a subscriber do
the same thing but also subscribe and
turn the notification about on so let me
explain something in recessions people
often get a bit afraid people think well
people are going to not be able to
afford staff there's gonna be money's
gonna dry up and there's a landlord your
tenants might not be able to afford to
pay rent no one wants to be a landlord
with a tenant there's not paying them
rent that's like one of the worst things
that can happen so there's a lot of
people saying that HMOs could dry up
because you're relying on lots of rent
normally when you have a house it's have
one tenant to deal with one tenant pain
maybe five or six hundred pounds a month
small house kushti no problem
you got a HMO you're expecting maybe
five or six tenants to pay you a rent of
400 pound amount each probably on
average so what happens if people can't
afford to pay rent anymore what are they
going to do well let me flip that on its
head a second well what are they gonna
do are they gonna say at the moment I'm
paying 400 pounds a month for this nice
room but now I'm struggling to afford
rent so instead I'm going to move out
and live in a house for 600 pound and
pay bills on top no listen
sessions rent normally go up not down
and in recessions people look for ways
where they can save money so if people
haven't got money and they're struggling
and they're trying to save costs which
they are right now people are trying to
save costs what are they gonna do
they're gonna try and find ways of
bringing their costs down and hey chair
mows as a product as a service and be
under no illusion every business is all
about supply and demand property
investing is a business your house is
your product your tenant is your
customer so HMO properties you're
offering a service where people can rent
very affordably have their bills
included 2020 I tell you what sells more
than anything convenience sells and
what's gonna happen what's gonna happen
is people are going to go from studio
apartments to bed flats and then they're
gonna say how can I save at the moment
I'm paying five hundred pound for the
studio flat and I'm paying two hundred
fifty pound my bills I know I'll go and
move into a house yet so I believe in my
opinion that HMOs are gonna get more and
more popular I believe that rents in HMO
properties are going to rise I also
believe that house prices it depends on
the area but house prices across the UK
generally speaking you're going to go
down there's going to be some areas that
I believe actually going to go up but
across the border they're going to go
down so if property prices go down
but within HMOs property rents are going
to go up which is my prediction what
does that mean for you a potential HMO
property investor what that means is it
means that your return on investment
your cash on cash is going to be higher
so previously where I've been teaching
how you can achieve 20% return on
investment I'll believe that what's
going to happen over the next six 12 18
months is it's going to become easier to
achieve that and potentially even
achieve 25 percent return on investment
which means that instead of having to
wait five years to get your money back
you're gonna have to wait four years
which is a really really good thing so
that's the rent side of HMOs also this
is really sad but divorces are spiking
at the moment and a lot of my tenants
that I've had are men who've recently
had a divorce or they've separated from
their families or partners and what
that's really sad you've got to look at
this from a business
spective I'm giving you my prediction on
what's going to happen with HMOs if two
if one household becomes two if guys are
leaving their their partners or getting
separated getting divorced HMOs are
really attractive so across the whole
account of how I see things I think that
rooms are going to become more and more
in demand convenient sells affordability
is good so that's my thoughts on the
demand however what about the supply of
HMOs they're bringing in something
called article four you've probably
heard about we speak about this before
article four is a restriction that the
council's put in place that says that
you cannot buy a property and then turn
it into a hey CH mo so if article four
was all across the whole country
overnight
that would mean that no more HMOs will
be able to come into existence unless
they happen to get planning permission
but getting planning permission on a
property converting into a haitch mo in
an article for area I think it's going
to be really really tough
so article 4 is a bad thing if it comes
in and then you've missed the boat
however if you buy a property in an area
that's non article 4 and then article 4
comes in you have the grandfather rights
you have automatic planning permission
so my advice would be not only is rents
gonna go up and generally property
prices are going to be going down but
when you buy a property and it becomes
article 4 or I think what's going to
happen is because no other houses can be
turned into HMOs what that does is it
caps the amount of HMOs so what does
what does that do to the value of your
HMO it means that your property the
value of it is going to go up so rents
are going to go up the value of HMOs are
going to go up so the only danger is
with HMOs is not buying HMO now waiting
a few years when article 4 is everywhere
and then missing the boat that's my
opinion so if I were you right now okay
and you're looking at buying a HMO
I would suggest find a hate term I'm in
a good area speak - hmm management
company make sure that it's going to
rent well I would make sure you're
getting a good return
make sure there's no article for and by
a hate demo property of course you've
got a deed allegiance you're going to be
checks because my opinion is that rents
are going to go up when article four
does come in the value is going to go up
you might think but what about
legislation and they're gonna bring you
more legislation with HMOs I can't see
that happening HMO is already very very
regulated and the rules basically say
this if the property it's got five or
more people in it you need a license if
there's less than five people in it you
don't need a license that's the general
rule of thumb however getting a license
isn't that bad and you can find all the
information for free on Google by
looking on the council's website you can
see what the rules are for a licensed
HMO it's not too difficult I am gonna be
running a webinar I'm gonna be going
into more detail on HMO property so if
you want to really get into the nooks
and crannies of HMOs I'll leave a link
in the description and you can see the
upcoming webinar on hmm properties so I
put it out there you heard it here first
it's 2020 I want you to look back on
this video in 2025 and you'll be able to
see that rents have gone up HMOs have
become more and more popular HMO values
have gone up but after before is going
to be probably in 2025 it's going to be
have covered the whole country and it's
going to be really really hard to get in
as of 2025 so now's the opportunity
now's the time let me know your thoughts
in the comments if you want to do some
more training on this as I say I'm
running a free webinar and any questions
pop them in on Sunday I'm going to be
doing a Q&A Sunday where you can ask me
questions directly and I'll do my best
to answer you guys thank you so much for
watching I look for to see you in the
next video peace out